what the hell's wrong with me I'm in the
schnauzer critic not the pusher fide
emotional cries over every Sesame Street
we're late to motion picture epic where
every person puppet educational crappy
animated animal tugs at your
heartstrings critic
Pusha fide emotional cries over at
Sesame Street related motion picture
travel to an effect for every person
puppet and occasional crab the animate
animal tugs at your heartstrings just
knock the emotional put supply press
over every Sesame Street where lay the
motion picture childhood epic where
every person puppet an occasional
cramping and oh not that puts it by the
emotional cries over every Sesame Street
relate a motion picture epic where
everybody's yuppies your pictures back
not the emotional cries over every
Sesame Street related motion picture
childhood everybody knows anything about
ha ha ha not that Pusha five emotional
cries over every Sesame Street will a
the motion picture epic which after a
judge Hatchett ha not the questions sure
not that puss applied emotional cries
over it's at them not we put some fish
ha not that Pusha 5 emotionally cry so
emotionally no not the push to fight
emotional cry so much
not the pusseh fight emotional cries
over Sesame Street related motion
picture childhood epics where every
person puppet and occasional crappy
animated animal tugs at your
heartstrings critic